let's start with this uh aoc quote
unquote attack uh here is alex stein
comedian and i guess we can call him a
rabble rouser on the capitol going after
aoc
see my favorite big booty latina i love
you aoc you're my favorite
she wants to kill babies but she's still
beautiful you look very beautiful in
that dress you look very sexy look at
that booty on aoc that's my favorite big
booty latina
i love it my favorite aoc nice to meet
you
okay so aoc heard him you know giving a
shout out to the booty she gave him the
peace sign clearly was not upset but
then later on when the video went viral
she realized he said the thing about
babies and abortion and then she got
very very upset and she issued this
response
i think the thing that was so crazy
about that incident is not even that it
happened but that it happened on the
capitol steps right in front of a
capitol police officer
and this dude was engaged like this
wasn't about a political opinion protest
or anything like that he was engaged in
very clearly sexually threatening
aggressive behavior
right in front on the capitol steps in
front of an officer and
he wasn't even asked to take a step back
like
this officer was just cool with it okay
so aoc doesn't like being harassed
except just a few days ago you guys
might remember that supreme court
justice brett kavanaugh had to leave a
morton's steakhouse in dc from the back
exit because a bunch of protesters were
out front here was aoc's tweet on that
she wrote poor guy he left before his
souffle because he decided half the
country should risk death if they have
an ectopic pregnancy within the wrong
state lines it's all very unfair to him
the least they could do is let him eat
cake uh kurt
do you think that
she doesn't get irony or that they are
the ones who have unleashed this or
there is an inconsistency here etc
well just a little bit what i what i
really like it well first of all i think
it's time that we shout out the racism
of this anti-sir mix-a-lot agenda that
she's obviously embraced
um i like big butts and i cannot lie
yeah but you know she tries to deny and
uh i you know if alex wants to uh uh you
know call out uh you know her uh amazing
latina booty in his words uh you know i
i actually prefer a sleeker latina booty
but that's you know that's that's my
personal call
uh i i think it's interesting that she
redefines the rules of politics where
you're allowed to intimidate people to
gain a political effect but then she
wants to regulate that she's like you
can you could bother him at a steakhouse
but you can't talk about her ass
i i
i
i i it's remarkable and i i just kind of
like scratched my head and said
who told you you get to decide all this
stuff
how about we'll do whatever we want
including you know talking about uh your
junk in the trunk and you can shut up
you
jibbering halfwit
because she's not a smart lady that's
you know that's not you know her brains
are not her biggest
ass fans if you get my
kurt i did say to my guys five minutes
before the show started we were going to
be demonetized on youtube just for me
saying your name and i'm sure that's
already happened so i'm glad you're here
my friend uh chad chad is the point here
with these guys uh that there's just no
level of irony they they simply don't
care if we expose them for saying you
can't protest these people uh or you
know you can't protest me but you can
protest these people or the tweets she
sent out that you may remember a couple
weeks back that the point of protest is
to make people uncomfortable but now of
course she's the victim
well you know you can point out the
hypocrisy over and over again of of the
left and the progressives and the wild
eyed woke um you know
you want you can't define a woman but
then men can't speak out about abortion
because they're not women you know and
then you go to this and
i don't think that aoc
uh
look she was a bartender she's used to
having cat calls i'm quite certain that
she did uh so this is but you know the
thing that's crazy about this is how
she's her big issue is more about the
capitol police officer who wasn't
defending her or something while her
boyfriend just walked the dog and walked
right on in
um you know and let's talk about you
know the hypocrisy is one thing and that
people have to understand
that's what a guy like alex stein
who is a comedian he's a prankster
this is a guy who puts on a women's
swimsuit and trolls city council
meetings um he is a he is comedy's shock
jock he's a friend he's opened several
shows for me i have watched
conservatives in the audience sit there
with mouths a gate of the things that
come out of his brain
uh he wanted to do this he was trolling
the hypocrisy for this very reason i
texted him you know as soon as i saw the
video
and he said she walked right into my
trap and you see the results of it